i'd like to introduce our speaker today
professor michael bernstein is an
associate professor of computer computer
science and the st microelectronics
faculty scholar at stanford university
he is a member of the human computer
interaction group and his research
focuses on the design of social
computing system his research has won
multiple awards at various conferences
and has also been featured in on the new
york times the new scientist wired and
the guardian
michael has been recognized by various
scholarships and awards
for his research and activities
he holds a bachelor's degree in symbolic
systems from stanford university and a
master's and phd degree in computer
science from mit uh and i'm sure you
will enjoy listening to him uh today so
with that i'll turn it over to michael
all right
hope you're all having a great day so
yeah that's right my name is michael and
we're gonna dive in we're going to talk
a bit about
design and ai and how that all sort of
meshes together into the future of what
products and interactive systems might
look like and what it might not look
like and how we actually understand
what's the right way to do this and
what's the wrong way to do this
so just to give a little bit of uh my
own picture i'm interested in how we
build interactive systems that bring
groups of people together and this is
often drawing on artificial intelligence
rat you know whether that is looking at
ways in which we can help use ai to make
teams uh better collaborators uh that we
can understand how crowdsourcing can
help uh measure and benchmark ais
building some technical infrastructure
looking at ways in which uh ideation can
be
can be collectively experienced this is
the kind of work that i spend a lot of
time thinking about i build these you
know everything from sort of algorithms
up all the way to
interactive systems and products uh in
the research world that i live in um
now
what i'm here to talk about today what
we want to discuss is how basically we
have this um we've had this sea change
and i'm going to start you know not
assuming much technical background here
just to sort of ex we're going to start
by talking about how there's been the
sea change in artificial intelligence or
ai and how it's gotten much better we're
going to talk about how that's
translating into organizations embedding
ai into their products into the
processes and and sort of this
divergence between some sometimes this
goes spectacularly well and sometimes it
goes uh
not quite as well as you'd expect
as you'd hope and so the question that
we're kind of here to talk about is how
do we make sure that our experience is
more on the spectacular side and the
less on the uh the the dumpster fire
so
i'm gonna start with a few terms okay
so when i talk about artificial
intelligence
we're talking about a subfield of
computer science that's trying to
automate performance on tasks that we
would normally consider to require
cognition of some sort to solve so we
usually think of cognition as residing
within our brains but there's a long
philosophical debate we we're going to
kind of allied here to just sort of say
when we talk about ai we're talking
about computers being able to do things
like say what's in this picture what
does the sentence mean how do i get
across this room in order to open the
door as a robot and so on
now ai's been trying to do this for many
many years uh and what's been happening
over time has been a revolution through
the uh an intersection of this with the
area of statistics this is called
machine learning machine learning
basically is not uh when it's not me
sitting in a room saying okay i think
this is how it should learn to open the
door instead we provide a lot of data
and that data trains the artificial
intelligence to sort of build a
statistical model of the world and then
it tries to act on it so just it's like
you know the the notion would be like
just like how a human baby's learning
through experience it's never given
rules these machines are learning
through experience
one more term deep learning you probably
hear this thrown around on the internet
on twitter and in academic circles quite
a bit uh this is essentially one
particular type of machine learning
model and it's a model that has driven
many of the improvements in ai over the
last decade you see when you when you
look at deep learning systems you're
often looking at something that has all
of these circles and lines connecting it
looking something like this
you can think of it as you you give it
some sort of input which i'm
representing here as a vector it's just
a bunch of different numbers or symbols
or whatever it would be and it is going
to feed that input to a series of
interconnected nodes that are learning
weights uh which again we're not going
to really get into but it's sort of
learning what to pay attention to
and what ends up happening at the end of
the day your organization will probably
have something along the lines of this
now this is not always how it works this
is what's called a supervised learning
but
generally many ai applications sort of
have this
general architecture so
you take a huge data set of example
inputs so let's say we're trying to uh
you know let's say i'm i'm redfin i'm
trying to to figure out for each picture
what kind of room is this is this a
bedroom a hallway is this a front shot
of the of the home or what so we got you
know 10 000 or maybe even many more
images
and then we produce what are called
labels for each example
and that's going to be the the thing
that we wanted to learn like this is a
bedroom this one's a hallway you know
this is a bathroom this is michael's
house he could better do better to keep
it up you know whatever it would be
these labels are attached to each of the
inputs so you have input label input
label input label input label and then
you have this deep learning architecture
so this is the this is the ai that tries
to now learn how to go from one of the
inputs to one of the labels it's trying
to predict the label
from the input so it's given a picture
it's never seen before of the house it's
going to try to say this is a hallway or
whatever
so we have all sorts of examples um
these are colleagues here at stanford
where
on the upper left is some work that uh
rajay krishna a recent phd alumnus of my
group in faithfully's group is doing to
try to say that this is a man flying a
kite that's what this picture is looking
at uh my colleague percy liang is trying
uh has projects looking at trying to
fill in blanks from sentences um i call
my colleague my colleagues uh jeannette
bogue and dorothy sadiq are learning how
to manipulate robot arms and so on from
human mappings it's trying to learn how
when i move the playstation controller
how should the robot be reacting these
are examples of sort of inputs outputs
and andrewing
another colleague at stanford i think
has has put this quite well in this hbr
article if you're trying to understand
what ai can and can't do we're talking
about progress through of a particular
type in which some kind of input data is
used to quickly generate some simple
response like input picture
response is there a face
uh a is there an english phrase
is the input is it inputs an english
phrase the output's a french phrase
translated and what he basically says
is that you know if if the typical
person can do this task with a less than
a second of thought we can probably
automate it with ai now or soon
and i think this is a not always a
perfect benchmark but i think it's a
pretty good way as you're considering
for your products what is ai going to be
able to do what's it really not going to
be able to do um what's what's the big
risk here
i would say like if someone can figure
this out
about less than a second of thought
maybe they're an expert in the domain
they can they can glance at it for you
know one to five seconds be like oh yeah
that's the answer it's probably
something that you would be able to
train an ai to do
so people are doing this to build ai
based products so ai you know was in the
research labs for many years and all of
a sudden
it's transforming many industries so
what's going on here what what do we do
about this and what i want to point out
here is that the the intersection with
us with people is where ai kind of lives
or dies right if if it successfully
interfaces with people then
we we make use of it and if it doesn't
we abandon it it's just like any
technology so i'll show a couple videos
here hopefully you'll be able to see
in in the window
the first one is an example from cynthia
brazil's group at the mit personal
robotics
group where again the point is not that
we've got some sort of magical ai that
is incredibly intelligent in fact this
this robot is not that intelligent but
the ways in which it communicates its
intense and and other parts of its state
to us really become critical uh here's
also anka dragon's work she's uh uc
berkeley does really interesting work in
this space uh ways finding ways in which
the robot can communicate what it's
likely to do so you could think like
should the robot be reaching as quickly
as possible for this thing or should it
be kind of wrapping around what is a
legible
and what i mean by legible or what she
means by legible is what is a movement
that people can predict what the ai is
going to do
so on one hand we have ai transforming
industries we have you know siri alexa
and so on creating whole new verticals
in more prosaic ways you have google you
know autocompleting your queries finding
ways to suggest ways you might want to
respond to that email in a friendly way
um but we have to think carefully and
this is work by wendy joo she's at
cornell tech
and uh it's it's an interesting example
of what happens when we don't do this so
what you're about to see is a video of
someone in a simulator of an automated
driving system and at some point the
automating driving system is going to
uh kind of lose the threat it's gonna
have to hand driving control back over
to uh nick here uh and who's as you can
probably tell staring at his cell phone
at the time so so this video is starting
and what i want you to pay attention to
is he's sitting there staring his phone
not really
driving
the exercise emergency
grabs it's a little confused
coming
and swears
and almost
so what's going on here is that the ai
was great until the moment that it
wasn't and that handoff back to the
person to the user to the end user here
was really risky and almost
almost produced an accident so we have
to understand these intersections now
there are successes so netflix as an
example is using an ai technique known
as recommender systems to essentially be
suggesting what we should be looking at
um shaping what kinds of stuff they
choose to build so they're using what's
called a recommender system their inputs
are what other people like or view you
know the thing is trying to predict what
other people will like or view and it
also produces these clusters of custom
at some customers and and clusters of
market segments and so on
now you also have something like stitch
fix the uh uh i think the shirt might
actually be from stitch fix uh where
they're personalizing their online
shopping experience where again the idea
is based on what other people would buy
what kind of clothes might i be
interested in so again we we see similar
things what are people liking or buying
what other people will like or buy
you have uh
the the google assistant you have siri
you have alexa um i'm sorry if my saying
the name is activating your smart thing
in your in your in your room because
that happens about half the time when i
give this talk these are all using
technologies ranging from spec text to
speech excuse me speech to text well and
text to speech uh as well as
uh interpreting what it is you're asking
for so the inputs here might look
something like just us a wave file like
a the sound of what someone's saying the
output would be some sort of
transcription and a structured request
and they have these rules for handling
the commands that's sort of the
architecture of how this thing works
zillow using computer vision to improve
property value estimates so they're
using something called computer vision
which is trying to make sense of
pictures uh again deep learning uh on a
regression meaning they're trying to
predict a continuous value so it's just
same deal input is a picture output how
much did this thing end up selling for
um here's google creating something to
help with that problem we've all had do
you know that song that goes
you know uh space jam dvd like the the
issue here is that
you want to be able to hum something and
produce back what song that is so the
inputs are
people humming the outputs that they
train this thing on in some level is a
melody a song
so even in the research and medical
world you have
products looking at ways in which you
can monitor your glucose if you're
diabetic right so again deep learning
regression just trying to predict
continuous value inputs
sensor values just stuff coming off of
your glucose sensor
outputs
ground truth measurements of glucose
levels and so
it's just trying to map these things
right it's saying
input is here's all the data we have
output is this is what it should have
learned your your ground truth glucose
level
uh fraud detection right so many of
these examples again activity sequences
on your website output trying to predict
was this an anomaly we labeled the
things that were anomalies can you help
us find more of them
ranking so here i'm a social media app
like facebook or twitter we want to know
what to put at the top so we're going to
again take these posts we're going to
try to predict we're then we're going to
rank with them so i i post something
like this on facebook it takes all the
features that it thinks might matter uh
how close you know roni and i are
whether this is a mobile phone photo
whether you're looking at this on your
website or your phone anything they
think might matter i'm just giving a
bunch of examples here
that all gets thrown into a big vector
that the deep learning system
tries to work on top of and trained to
predict
some notion of engagement which it'll
call a relevant score so that might be
will you like it well you click it well
you comment on it this is what uh
facebook is trying to learn
so how and and what it does from this is
start to then rank the items so it says
here are these scores for every single
thing in your in your news feed i'm just
going to sort your news feed by that
score
okay so that's a ton of examples
what is this all about really
i'm going to use this term intelligence
augmentation it's a it's i like the term
because it's an inversion of ai
literally so when we talk about a.i or
artificial intelligence this is the
opposite ia intelligence augmentation
which is really a reaction to this
notion that ai's is going to take over
all our jobs
right
i think it is
um
hopefully well established at this point
that ai doesn't just
push out jobs it replaces parts of jobs
it does push out some jobs in which case
i think we need to really talk at a
societal level about what what that
pathway looks like but at the same time
in many cases what's actually happening
is that ai is sort of entering the job
in ways that we have to figure out how
we're going to how we're going to
integrate with it and the best case what
you would look hope for is something
that sort of is a cognitive amplifier
sort of like a prosthesis for our brain
that makes us smarter this here's a
picture of douglas engelbart a turing
award winner who envisioned many of
these ideas originally when he was at
the stanford research institute or sri
it was all about trying to push back on
this notion that ai is this entirely
autonomous thing that we're going to
replace human intelligence with
artificial intelligence his vision of
intelligence augmentation or ia was one
in which these machines are being used
to make us smarter can we be less biased
can we be more predictive of the things
that we want to be predictive of can we
essentially be better at what we're
trying to achieve
that's the idea of intelligence
augmentation
now this all sounds great
but
ai doesn't always work
and as um my colleague etan adar at the
university of michigan likes to point
out i love this quote of his never let
your use your ui or your user interface
write a check that your ai can't cache
what he means by that is that people end
up building these interfaces that are
sort of promising the world and the ai
ultimately can't
execute on it i think if you want to
really uh close to home example if
you've ever played with again your siri
your alexa your your google your
whatever it would be um
the first time you you use it you start
trying to ask all sorts of interesting
things like you know when's my when's my
aunt coming to visit or you know what's
the weather next tuesday at 5 00 p.m in
you know
and very quickly you find out that these
systems are
uber brittle
that they don't work as well as you
would want and what what the research
literature shows is that people then
sort of collapse into a a small
singularity of of things that they end
up doing so
like oh okay i'll just ask it to set a
timer because i know it can do that so
this user interface of something like
siri or alexa saying just talk to me
i'll do whatever you want in reality the
ai can't cache that check
so it's it becomes a problematic thing
so you have to make sure you're not
overreaching what the ai can actually do
so just to give a sense of what
products might actually look like uh
here are some some visions from the
research literature over the last 10 or
or so years you know again the research
literature tends to work you know 10 25
to 5 to 25 years out so you know uh if
you're a programmer you might not just
imagine like codex like having open ai
write your code for you you might
imagine being able to write scripts that
actually are
using visual inputs so i can say
something like hey whenever i've got
this on this google map that's tracking
the bus routes or something what i want
it to do is just i want to say hey
whenever you find the bus
inside of this area of the new haven map
send me a text message
i don't know how to write that in like
traditional code but i can certainly
take screenshots and i can say hey if
you see this thing inside of this other
thing let me know this is solving a real
human problem is it has been for me as
i've had to deal with uh commuter issues
over over the course of my life you know
it's a simple script but really hard to
explain without ai
so you might have other examples where
uh here see if i can uh push this slide
to you
um
let's see okay here we go so the you
know here's an example of disaggregation
where imagine you want you just wanted
to have uh one
one thing on your on your on the outside
of your house that was just telling you
how much water is my sink using how much
water is my tub using how much water is
my shower using well normally you'd have
to instrument every single piece of your
house but it turns out some folks at the
university of washington uh have found
that whenever you turn on your faucet or
your tub or whatever there are very
characteristic changes in the water
pressure of your entire pipe system in
your house and through machine learning
they can then identify when each of your
various uh utilities is being used and
then turn that into
the the one use that i've seen for those
displays that sometimes they try to put
on refrigerators that's showing you what
your water usage is like you can imagine
all sorts of different visualizations of
your water usage just by attaching a
single sensor to kind of like the hose
on the outside of your house
here's an example for accessibility
reasons um this is imagine if our user
interfaces for for our phones for our
computers could adapt to people with uh
based on their on their motor abilities
so here you might see uh like old school
uh print dialogue but and then below it
you would see one that was designed for
someone with limited motor dexterity so
it's made certain aspects of the of the
interface larger uh or and changed some
of the the things from drop downs to
buttons and so on based on a model of
what this individual is good and bad at
doing and this is you know it basically
is able to to train off of this to
create way fewer errors so imagine if
our systems could become more responsive
to our own my own aging as i as i start
to lose my hair um so
fashion mining right looking at ways in
which this might impact fashion so
imagine you wanted to be able to say
this is what i need an outfit that sort
of has the following characteristics
it's sort of beachy and tropical being
able to model this and suggest what that
might look like
if you're any sort of graphic designer
imagine being able to as these folks
from mit did
create
the uh something that can show you what
people are paying attention to so it's
estimating eye gaze at a visual stimulus
so here's a poster and as i move text
around you can see in the video here
that it's actually saying with with the
hot spots here's what people are going
to attend to on this you notice sort of
as i move things around and change the
weights of fonts and so on it's changing
what people are and are not paying
attention to in the poster this is
something that visual designers usually
can't do but if we can start to model
through ai what people look at then we
can maybe start thinking uh sort of
getting out of our own head as designers
a bit more
also in spaces like ubiquitous computing
and internet of things
gesture recognition without having tons
of you know vr stuff attached to us
here's uh gabe cohn uh who's at the time
working at microsoft research basically
showing that by just paying attention to
sort of the electromatic magnetic stuff
that's bouncing off of our light bulbs
in our in our uh in the rooms all the
time it can start to identify when when
i'm going through various gestures you
might imagine gesturing to like you know
shut up the the phone when it rings or
something if you're in the middle of a
talk not that that's ever happened to me
um
or how stressed you are imagine if your
if your car could detect if you were
particularly stressed out and as a
result could uh start to
you know maybe be aware you know cut
down external noises and so on um this
is pablo paredes who demonstrating that
just by modeling how sort of tense you
are as you grip the steering wheel that
wheel they can actually estimate how
stret your your levels of stress
so um drawing on some work from my
colleague scott clemmer
i want to talk a bit about how we create
products so this is going to be sort of
part two
part one was about what what's coming
down the pike what might this look like
part two is how do we actually go about
doing this
now
i'm at stanford at stanford we teach
this
this comes out of the stanford d-school
it's design thinking there's these sort
of sets of interrelated loops going from
understanding to observing creating a
point of view on what it is you're
trying to do ideating prototyping and
testing
and when you think about it this this
this is intended to be useful across
essentially you know more or less any
interactive or non-interactive product
you might create
now you throw ai into the mix and the
question becomes
why does this get so much harder why do
we keep screwing up
like which which part of this process is
really tough
and for my money it's the prototyping
stage
because we went from a world in which
you can sort of you know create
something
uh
with that's you know static with pen and
paper for us to play with and try out to
something where you have to get a
full-fledged ai model working and that's
a problem
from the perspective of of you know
putting a bunch of effort into something
that ends up being a dud
so
you know when i talk about a prototype i
mean something like this this is uh
prototypes of the original mouse that
microsoft the first one that microsoft
put out which is the mouse that
basically many of us uh who are elder
millennials like myself and older
recognized as sort of the first largely
successful commercial mouse it wasn't
the first one but it was the one but
microsoft had such a large install base
that it was essentially the first one
that many people experienced and what
you can see here in the background are
all these prototypes of different
versions of the mouse that microsoft
tried on the along the way to the final
product which you can see snaking its
way through the middle and if you stare
at them you can see how each prototype
is a question each of these prototypes
is exploring
some question they're trying to answer
like what if what if the mouse were kind
of arced like like my hand sort of in a
semicircle what if the buttons were sort
of very obviously offset in different
sizes what if they had different
textures what if it kind of felt like a
bar of soap what if it was really
angular they're playing with all these
different versions of it how would you
do that with an ai in which in which you
like you would it would take tens of
hours maybe even months to create each
version of these things
so if we go with this notion again from
scott that a prototype is a rapid
approximation of a design idea that
you're using to gather feedback
how do you gather feedback well
traditionally what i would teach in like
an intro course is do this thing called
paper prototyping where you make your
interface on paper
and uh you and then you sort of let them
click you know sort of tap on it and you
learn about it so okay now is this app
useful or not
now the problem is how do you make a
paper app that's got an ai behind it now
it turns out they actually asked this
question back in the 80s through
something that they ended up calling
wizard of oz prototyping and i think
this is actually
becoming sort of back in vogue in a way
that uh we haven't really seen in a
while the idea behind a wizard of oz
prototype is that you have someone kind
of behind the curtain you can see
someone here under the table uh who's
effectively responsible for turning the
light on and off so that so the user is
there you know playing with this
interactive room so to speak uh that
appears really intelligent when in
reality essentially there's someone
behind the curtain pretending to be the
ai and what this does is it lets us kind
of mock in the existence of the ai by
doing it manually
instead
of uh trying to build the whole thing
only to find out that it won't be useful
so essentially it says imagine we had
this ai
and then uh what would happen
if if if it worked and that's what a
wizard of oz prototype
does
this essentially lets us play uh kind of
a game of time travel so that we can
figure out whether this system is
actually even worth building in the
first place
so
making a wizard of oz prototype isn't
too complicated what we end up doing is
starting with the traditional stuff that
we might do we map out the scenarios the
application flow we build this low
fidelity prototype you know often again
using paper and then we sort of
develop a contract or a script so to
speak that says okay wizard human person
on my team whenever the user does this
you should sort of interpret it in the
following way and respond in the
following way so it might mean that
you'll
this is the thing that's later going to
be replaced with the ai but for now it's
going to be me or it's going to be
rooney or it's going to be uh
anyone else
and the wizard is going to basically
just pretend that the ai works pretty
well enough how would it you know just
pretend how might an ai react to this
input
maybe you should play with what happens
if it gets it wrong you know understand
maybe
you never design assuming the ai is
going to be perfect because it's not i
promise you
so you then have a facilitator this is
someone who's kind of guiding the user
through the through the experience and
then behind the scenes there is a wizard
who's kind of operating the interface
they are playing the role of of the
robot of the ai
and then as as you bring people in they
can interact with your system maybe it's
your new maps directions or maybe it's
your recommendations for uh music you
ought to listen to or podcasts or
whatever it is that you're building and
the wizard you know is more slow than an
ai but comes in and can operate the
interface
and then you can talk to them just like
you would any other usability study
so
what we you know we start to see these
things actually even sometimes put into
practice so this was a um a social q a
app called aardvark as reported on in
the wall street journal where it was
trying to connect people to
people with questions to people who
could answer those questions and instead
of just you know spending years in in
uh skunk works trying to train the ai to
be perfect at this and actually started
out with this wizard of oz scheme they
would get questions from the beta users
and they would just manually route them
they'd be like oh yeah it's totally a
smart ai yeah definitely an ai doing
this when they're sitting there behind a
computer screen and routing things
manually so it was all entirely done to
make sure that the concept was
worthwhile and as a side effect it
produced a bunch of training data for
them to actually train the final ai on
top of it now this is no panacea right
it definitely is faster and cheaper and
more iterative it's more real than
trying to do something that's kind of a
dead paper prototype um and you learn by
what happens when the wizard's being
pushed into weird situations that you
didn't expect
on the downside it's not an ai so the
the errors that it makes will be
different than what an ai might
eventually be able to do and it's slower
right it's it's kind of like okay now
wait the wizard's gonna have to think
for a minute and you know shuffle some
paper for you
so it's it's not a perfect approximation
but it's a thing that you can do in
three hours in an afternoon and i
promise you you will learn much more in
those three hours than spending weeks
putting together an initial version of
the ai to do it yourself
so if you were going to think about it
you might try out a prototype like how
would you prototype an ai that knows you
know that's that's like your cell phone
camera that's going to say you know what
you know that's a great photo michael
but maybe you ought to like move it down
or up or or change the framing you know
so that you look good
right how would you prototype that with
a wizard of oz well you might have
someone holding just you know again a
standard cell phone camera and then you
might have the wizard who knows
something about about photo composition
kind of over their shoulder wearing
masks of course uh because this is 2022
exactly um and
the
and and sort of making those suggestions
and and you can see whether the person
adopts them do they understand it or not
another example
an energy plant safety system using ai
to identify normally anomalies and alarm
technicians
so maybe you're you're working at the
energy in the energy industry already
you go visit some folks who are who are
technicians you have them sort of go
through one of their training sessions
and in one of the training sessions
you're including an additional pretend
ai
and you see how they react to it they
might say well i don't know if i can
trust this it depends on what signals
it's looking at like when you start to
learn what it is that they need out of
the ai before you finish building it
uh or an audio application that's trying
to predict you know what music i want to
play right now based on you know based
on my mood this is sort of a classic
thing that like every student
wants to do at some point or another and
you know again what would the wizard be
doing grab someone who uh who has good
taste and
is uh trying to make suggestions see
what people how people react to that if
they don't react to it well with a
pretty good human version then the ai
version whether it's better or about
about the same also not going to be
reacted too well
now i want to show one other sort of
bleeding edge idea this is something
we're actually currently doing in my lab
at stanford um and it is
i think gonna make some substantial
changes to how we build in prototype ai
systems so this has to do with
lane what are called large language
models um you may have heard of
something called gpt3 as one famous
version of this but there are a number
of them hugging face and others have
really good ones
the idea is that these systems for the
first time enable essentially a natural
language input to the ai where you can
sort of tell it what you want and it
will produce uh a response
and it can crap you can sort of craft
nearly any ai that the ai could create
so you know here in some research we've
been doing we're interested in creating
i don't know here's a we want an ai that
can tell whether this online comment and
say the q a for this uh for this uh
webinar
is civil right and civil like we know we
don't want the being civil stuff here uh
you know please be polite so you just
tell the ai this is literally what you
would tell gpt3 the large language model
we're trying to determine whether this
forum comment is silver and civil
imagine you read the following comment
on a forum go shut your shelf itself in
the room and think about what you just
wrote so you just posted that to the uh
to the chat in here and then you you
write q would you consider this comment
to be civil or in civil a this comment
is
and gpt3 is expected to finish the
sentence
i never trained this ai there was no
training yet and i didn't have to
generate 10 000 examples i actually just
read the entire web effectively or a
curated version of it and learned to
predict
what might happen next if it were given
this prompt
and it would produce something like say
in civil
literally just i spent five minutes
writing this prompt and all of a sudden
i have an ai that i could sort of use as
a prototype is it gonna be as good as
one that i fine tune and make manually
maybe not
but is it good enough to kind of
quickly get a sense of whether the ai
can do this and how it'll behave and
wire it into a simple prototype
absolutely i think this is going to
change the game in my opinion
so given the results of the prototype
like this you iterate
right so now we'd be by having tightened
this prototyping loop we can go through
more iterations we can explore more
ideas and we can avoid releasing duds
so
i think that leaves us with the question
of what next
right where are we going to go from here
i think what we're going to start to see
is not we will see some entirely new
product categories but i think probably
in aggregate the bigger impact is going
to be ai's being integrated into many
many many products that we use today to
sort of slightly enhance the experience
to be slightly smarter slightly more
user friendly and so on i i hope that
you use this not to displace human
intelligence but to augment it
right to help us be smarter at what we
do
and so if i'm just pulling this all
together we have this opportunity to
think about how we're going to design
products that draw on everything from
sensor data to human language to
open-ended input
and that they're typically going to
produce fairly simple responses and if
you fall into that kind of category
you're in a space where ai can help
now
at the end of the day and i think this
is where a lot of the technologists miss
it
even the best ai is useless if you're
not solving a problem that people care
about
so we actually have to invert that
because i think one of the things that i
was trying to get across today you have
to invert and start by asking is this
solving a meaningful problem through
prototyping it
before you invest all the time to create
these complicated deep learning models
it's really seductive so seductive to
just go train the thing
i know it i've been there but it's
almost always the wrong idea
so instead we use some sort of
prototyping technique to see if we built
this and it worked pretty well
what would the experience be like and if
that's promising pursue it further
so i will wrap here i wanted to leave
lots of time for q a i'm going to hand
this back off to my colleague rony for a
few minutes and then we will engage in
some discussion which is you know always
the fun part
so one thing that i think you mentioned
early on michael in the talk is how uh
training the ai systems can be quite
complicated and difficult and i think
that as people think about ai one thing
that's often overlooked is the amount of
data that's needed in order to
effectively train these ai systems and i
was wondering what are some ways that
you've seen companies address this need
to get kind of massive amounts of data
sort of trained because if you have any
examples of effective ways to do that
sure well i think there are kind of two
common models one is
when
there the company sort of has its own
oroboros that is to say where it can
train on behavioral data that it already
has access to
netflix can train on whether you end up
watching a show that it recommends it
can create little experiments and
you know just say people watch this but
not this or they started this and they
abandoned it
facebook has signals like whether you uh
you like a piece of content or not uh
now these behavioral metrics are
inevitably incomplete
right and as we've seen with uh facebook
and others when all you're doing is
trying to maximize engagement it can
lead to some really negative outcomes
right so
that there are
it can be a very effective way of kind
of bootstrapping
but it inevitably kind of hits some
important limits uh and creates
problematic issues down downstream now
we can maybe there are questions later i
have an entire other talk i could give
about sort of ethics and product design
of ai systems uh i'm gonna put that in a
box for a moment um other than saying
there are ways to do that better as well
the the second way that i tend to see
this happen
is through manual labeling so the
company will
curate some part of
uh the data set and then we'll go to
either some internal
uh set of annotators that they've hired
so many many major tech companies either
have
their own workforces mary gray has an
excellent book on this called ghost work
if you want to learn about how this
works um
a common one today is appen app en that
many companies will turn to to get the
the data labeled for them um this is you
know often referred to as crowdsourcing
or data annotation and they will go and
you know get something on the order of
ten thousand or a hundred thousand of
these of these items that they that they
grabbed annotated and then ultimately
they go try to try to train the model on
it look at the errors that it makes try
to go find more examples in those spaces
where the errors are go label more data
there and and iterate you know there's
no it's always an iterative process and
it always takes more time than you'd
like
perfect thank you so i there are a few
there are quite a few questions related
to the prototyping and the wizard of oz
um kind of idea and i i guess maybe
let's start with a question that has to
do with prototyping in general um
basically as i understood your uh
explanation of the wizard of oz
prototype we're trying to understand
whether an idea has any merit regardless
of whether it's an ai based idea or not
we're trying to figure out if there is a
need for it in the market and how will
users react to it uh and i guess that's
an idea that's probably true across any
product development activity uh
what how easy or difficult is it for for
in companies that you've seen to pick up
this idea and really start to use
prototyping as a daily practice that
they kind of implement uh in their
company what are some uh
suggestions for making this successful
uh in a company if you want to make it
make this kind of a mindset uh that
you're you're
pushing
yeah
so this is um
you know it's it's a shift in the
culture of the company to succeed at
like you know a culture of prototyping
and just to sort of put as fine a point
on it as i can
many companies have brainstorming
sessions decide what they you know in
those internal brainstorming sessions
what what's going to be
valuable and then we'll basically put
out a bunch of engineering goals and
they'll build that thing and they'll
launch it
if you're sort of design thinking
prototype in method what you're doing is
you're instead saying okay that does
seem like a great idea what's our
riskiest aspect of that idea how do we
build a prototype that isolates and just
reduces the risk in that dimension so
for example uh you know we once had a
project that was looking at trying to
see whether if we uh could use ai's to
intelligently suggest
norm shifts in team collaborations like
in you know imagine a little bot in
slack that's saying something like hey i
know this sounds a little silly but uh
what if you all you know
sort of appointed a leader for the next
hour or what i know this sounds a little
silly but what if you all tried to sort
of be kind of a little little extra
peppy for the next hour just try it um
and we're learning what what's working
what's not now what we end up doing is
like yeah we could build this whole ai
but in at the end of the day we can
convene some teams and do this
like the big risk is does do people like
pay attention to this it's not like
could the ai learn this yeah we could
probably learn something right but is
this actually going to change behavior
is the big question
that's why we build the prototype is the
prototype lets us strip away everything
except that biggest risk and focus just
entirely on that vector and we say okay
well people seem to adjust for it but
now now there's a different biggest risk
would anyone ever realistically you know
spend enough time with this system for
it to learn something okay well then for
that the question that we need to
prototype the answer to is like well how
quickly could it actually learn and
there we create a very basic version of
the ai and see how many you know we in a
simulation or something like that so how
many uh iterations does it need to learn
something and so every point we're just
trying to kind of squish in this vector
squishing that vector's question is that
each of those is a prototype and the
prototypes are sort of disposable but
over time we gain that confidence
if you want resources for this kind of
stuff i would look at scott clemmer's
online coursera course uh which teaches
uh the sort of human centered design
principles for for interactive systems
anything that comes out of the stanford
d school on the design thinking process
um you know ido uh inhibits it
excuse me inhabits much of this you know
it's it's really a mindset shift in how
you go about product design and
development
wonderful and so then if we take if we
kind of continuing a little bit on this
prototyping was our device path
now if we're thinking of a specific
prototype to test an ai uh system a
wizard of oz prototype like you
described can you describe the path of
what happens after you've done the you
know you've done the prototype what are
some metrics that you use to determine
whether this the user is interacting
well with this and it's worth continuing
uh and how would you take it to the next
stage in the process
sure you know in in bill buxton's book
sketching user experiences he makes what
i think is an excellent excellent
distinction between
getting the right design and getting the
design right
what he means by that is that there's a
difference between sort of picking the
right product to create
and then sort of iterating your way
toward the best version of that product
getting the right design
sort of is picking which mountain you're
gonna which hill you're gonna climb and
get and getting the design right is
climbing that hill
so when you talk about metrics you have
to think about first which of those two
things am i trying to do am i trying to
say
i talk about what's the risk like is
there an existential threat of whether
people would actually make use of this
system then the metrics you're actually
paying attention to are something like
do they you know do they adopt it in
their in their usage
in the task or whatever uh or do they
just ignore it or do they find it you
know grading or do they stop using it
after you know 24 hours
whereas if you're trying to get the
design right and iterate then it's
actually you know you may have some some
other metrics that you would care about
that are a little bit more micro
and so i actually think those metrics
are selected based on what your current
goal or problem is so i could give you
essentially
some ones i would use but ultimately
what i would do is i would start by
asking am i getting the right design
right now or am i getting the design
right right now and if i'm getting the
right design i'm trying to sort of
what i'm trying to essentially ask is
is this thing worth pursuing at all or
should i change it substantially if
you're getting the design right then
it's sort of like you're asking
questions more like where do they get
caught up what what kind of errors are
happening where are the bumps in the
road you don't care about the bumps in
the road if if you're not even sure if
this is if you haven't proven to
yourself this is the right thing to
build but once you've decided that it is
then yeah the bumps matter a lot
that's great
um so we've gotten a few questions about
the notion of intelligence augmentation
or ia
and i wanted to see if you can share
some examples on how this might impact
work so you said uh you know some folks
are worried that with ai jobs are going
to go away and and i it looks like
through your description of the ia
um basically we're looking at helping
people perform their tasks better um is
that a right representation and what
else can you say about its impact on on
future work
sure
so
if you want to learn more about this i
would point you at my colleague eric
grenielsen
uh who's
who's here at stanford
and some work that he and others have
done i think make it an astute point
that it's not that jobs quote unquote
are the right jobs are not the right
unit of analysis for when you're
considering what ai will displace like
people used to say oh you know
we're going to lose all teachers or
something like this we're not going to
lose all teachers but what will happen
is that tasks within jobs are going to
get displaced
so you can ask something like is grading
going to change
or
is you know
long-haul trucking just like when you're
when you're in a straightaway is that
going to change
and i think the thing to ask is
what's going to happen
when this task gets displaced from this
job
by ai
is it something where
now the worker's going to be forced to
do more faster
and is that an outcome we want
um you know is it doing something sort
of against their will
in a sort of tailorist point of view is
it something where it's going to help
you know me in an information
uh like
challenging environment like i'm i don't
know i'm trying to make some product
decision
make me uh smarter at making that
decision that's the space where i think
we should be investing more energy i you
know i think that there is
so much that just sort of tries to
picture ai as a black box that's going
to sort of fit in and sort of
you pull out some old
other piece of the clock and you know
you put in the shiny new part
i think that's totally wrong i think
instead
we want to be thinking about
what are what are these ultimately in
service of who's you know whose
expertise can be augmented here and i
think that essentially it's about asking
like what are the tasks that each of the
each of us in our jobs are engaged in
and what is and is not a good impedance
match for for that technology i think
we'll find that a lot of stuff
isn't you know um maybe i'm like look
i'm in a computer science department i'm
not a luddite but like when you know
when when there's
so much smoke around
the metaverse and uh and
your crypto stuff and and ai like i
think we have to ask what problem what
human problem is being solved
and make sure that there's
you know i think that's what tells us
like what's actually at the core of this
or is the rest of it just you know sort
of techno babble
um okay so i guess probably two final
questions so uh
what what in your opinion what industry
is moving the fastest and
has the most investment in ai and what
are some industries that could use more
kind of investment resources and focus
uh and benefit from additional ai tools
or products
well the first half of that problem of
that question seems easier so i'll start
there which is basically the tech
industry the tech industry for a long
time has been very data driven it knows
how to do data warehousing it like had
has the technology technical expertise
internally
to train these models and so i think you
saw
silicon valley
adopting this fairly early on
even when it was less
less
performant than it was today
in terms of verticals that
have been behind
you know i think a lot of the challenge
is that for many of these verticals they
are
um
they less naturally have data
so if you think of many many um
many applications in say like
sustainability climate um environment
like sensing is really hard in those
environments you can't like just go like
throw smart dust through it through a
forest to understand uh you know changes
in temperature and humidity and and
flora and fauna like that's it's really
tough and so you know
i've colleagues at stanford who are
working on this and they end up you know
using things like satellite data to try
to make inroads and it's because there's
so little structured data so i think
that the the
these are domains that could be
truly transformed
if the data were there
but the sensing layer kind of remains a
challenge
um
i think that another thing that a sort
of a slow revolution that we will see
that's starting already but will
continue is around
basically medicine human you know human
health
um again this is a space where we are
very cautious about deploying new
interventions
and
and so i think that that that's less
about
technical
issues those those exist
and more about sort of ethical issues
practice practice issues regulatory
issues i think we'll see it over time
though
great that's super helpful
um okay so i guess our last uh question
for today which is a big question and
probably a topic for a different talk or
lecture but we've spoken or we hear a
lot
said about bias in ai
what are some uh ways to address that
what are some things that you want to
highlight as we close out this talk
related to biases in ai systems
oh my gosh
i want to give a whole nother talk now
okay so i'll try to give the shortest
version of that of this that i can
ai saying that ai has the has the
possibility of creating
negative impacts on our society it's
like that's a horse that's left the barn
like it's
so gone that like the horse has like you
know race across state lines raced
across the continent and like gotten a
shoot the shoe company scholarship like
it's it's like it's it's a huge issue
and there's some really excellent work
um you know in communities looking at
like fairmell um timnit gibru and and
many others have been involved uh
benjamin if you look at her her work um
especially coming out of many uh folks
who are like um women and people of
color i strongly strongly encourage you
to read their their work not people who
look like me uh on these issues but
there are basically two things that i
think are going on one is the models are
picking up on
implicit biases in the data so
um you know an early example of this had
to do with recidivism prediction in the
justice system turns out you know there
are biases in who sort of winds up in
the justice system and and you know
getting picked up by crime that has has
nothing to do with the person's color
uh but the algorithms learn that
that pattern
and then what they're trying to do these
algorithms are essentially trying to say
look we want the algorithm to still work
but we want it to sort of have protected
classes that it should be you know
equally uh
treating say uh whites and people of
color so it's sort of like saying we
know the data coming into this is
problematic and the and we're going to
try to sort of uh
boil it off a little bit and try to fix
the issue um this is there's been a lot
of work in this space i strongly
strongly encourage you to check it out
um also work that's just trying to
document the issue like data sheets for
data sets
or algorithm audits
really good work
the other sort of issue here is how
these things get deployed in
sort of structurally racist ways so you
could have a perfectly fair algorithm
and then hand it off to a judge who
decides conveniently to ignore it when
it sort of disagrees with with their gut
uh my colleague angel christine here at
stanford has has
investigated this
and so
from that perspective it's totally
incoherent to focus only on removing the
bias from the model itself we have to
remember that these models are getting
embedded in products that are embedded
themselves in like structurally racist
and sexist systems
and so for that you have to sort of ask
how is this thing going to be abused
what groups are going to be harmed by
this and again i keep gesticulating
toward this being another talk if you
want to see about it uh we might i
recently published a paper in the
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences that's showing what we're doing
here at stanford to deal with that it's
collaboratively with margaret levy in
political science uh ethicists
biomedical ethicists and so on and what
we're essentially doing is early
projects are being
reviewed by an interdisciplinary panel
of experts asking what are the possible
issues with this once this thing goes
big like if it leaves the lab it becomes
commercialized gets used by an
authoritarian government trying to
foresee what those issues might be and
introduce mitigating approaches early on
long before the horse leaves the barn so
i think that that's ultimately what we
need as we're talking about
the impacts of these things on society
so again i've much to say about this
wasn't really designed to be the topic
of this particular presentation but it
is um
it's a thing that has to be integrated
into every product development process
or you're going to end up with some
really embarrassing egg on your face and
you're going to harm people so that's
why the reason it's embarrassing right
you probably didn't intend that
thank you this is this has been fabulous
and i think uh
definitely incentivized to listen to the
the other talks and read the other um
the other publications that you've had
on this topic uh so i would like to
close off the webinar now i've seen lots
of questions about different references
that michael made to to other speakers
to to books to talks please i will be
sharing the recording of the webinar and
i suggest that's probably the best way
to uh kind of go back and and see what
those were um and i want to thank
professor bernstein again for joining us
today and i want to thank all of you for
spending this hour with us and we hope
to see you again in one of our future
programs goodbye everyone
you